[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classics it's day seven of
nine in the 2017 spring chess classics
and this thing isn't over yet the
questions are who will walk away with an
improved name and standing in the chess
world and of course the prize money the
2017 spring chess classic features a
combined prize fund of more than 50
grand win the top prize in group a that
will get you $6,000 $4,000 is the prize
for group V and the top prize for group
C is $5,000 that's because Group C is
actually stronger than Group B after
seven vara Cobian leads Group A with
Darius spirits and yarrow zero book hot
on a tail
tomorrow's key games include zero book
person a Fattah and Zhang versus spirit
can the second and third places advance
up the leaderboard
I'm here with international master a
wonder Liang and he is sitting with six
and a half points with two rounds left
to go that's pretty good I tell your
chances of winning the field are pretty
good what are you saying
I guess it definitely left two games but
you have op shop and Palouse yes okay
well I mean you got a full point right
now as we speak so and cheerless sir
that was 5 out of 5
like me so it's still not so clear yet
again not so clear it's I don't want to
jinx it I don't want to jinx it but it's
stacked in your favor
fourteen year old of Wonderland I wonder
today you had white against Navi Pocky
day and you came away with the victory
so let's take a look at the game and
show us what happened I think in this
position like quite a few choices were
pretty good for black
even after b5 it wasn't that bad because
after takes takes rook e1 I think would
be it was a pretty strong move and this
rookie said a 95 again so I think I was
dying to play like h3 maybe King g2 like
came g2
not exactly sure what blackened play
here but it checked for like two seconds
with the computer says it's equal but
not so sure it was that easy for black
either here maybe like h6 or something
because it's kind of difficult to move
any pieces a 95 is also possible always
here in this position with this kind of
endgame and then I think white should be
better here as well so it's not really
possible to do that
another possibility was also look a
eight I guess that's a rookie 795 with
descent King f6 is strong again so we
create and now I think I was planning to
play like should be four to c5 and I
think what should be study butter but
again I don't think it's that much
because black is always very solid so
after rook take c1 yike thought this was
kind of a mistake I should bet for now
b3 was kind of strong but it I kind of
overestimate this move early on because
I realized that after a TS b3 this
bishops c1 a for should be to a5 it son
it's not so clear which Knight move is
the best
I thought nice c8 was better
d5 takes takes it should be four I
wasn't sure about the valuation of this
endgame I guess like King f1 he was
reasonable I thought it should be pretty
difficult for black to defend with a
pawn and the weak King side comes with
the two bishops but what an Aussie did
didn't really make much sense if she saw
this line because after 95 be a four we
should be eight you get like the same
type of position but I have an extra
pawn a three so that's pretty good for
white I guess does in many lines like
let's say after Bishop takes a four-ship
take c6 Knight c7 I guess like after I
play like push a6 and then I couldn't
bring the other pawn to e5 and put the
bishop on b6 so should be willing um
instead she played Knight f4 Bishop
takes c6 92 check it should be 5 yeah
like I said I think the Sun game should
be lost for black are these very
difficult to defend
but after 92 I think it's already
clearly lost because we should take
should be 2 in Bishop e3 and once this
Bishop is trade the knight would be very
passive against a pawn so I guess
there's very little hope now which it
takes king e - there was one nuance I
guess if Bishop c6 with the idea of
Bishop d7 there's 94 so unfortunately I
can't wrap the night like that but
Bishop takes a 7 B waiting anyway
looking up 6 King be 3 yeah there's a
little trap here after Bishop takes f7
knight c6 and night before check but
after Kings before black just gets into
this one eventually and f4 yeah so if I
guess H 5 H 4 winds basically because if
the knight ever moves then I have Bishop
after a king d8 King b6 and there's no
Knight to c8 Lester like f 3 H 4 4 h5
after Knight g8 well if I play like
which it takes us three now then King be
king b6 Knight see a check which is
still winning 4 right but it just takes
longer and after h5 blacks is 6 1
because after King baking b6 wins
so I guess after an idea Bishop takes up
three yeah this is basically winning all
right well great job thank you for going
over the game with me um I wonder you
are playing once again in the 2017 u.s.
junior close championship moments ago
signing the contract very enlightening
stuff but you've been an event for a few
years now and we pretty used to be
playing in that just 2x
just to okay would you say that you have
a rival amongst the juniors at this
point I mean Geoffrey xiong has been
beating me quite often I'm not sure if
he's playing this time well that's
that's the million-dollar question
really because last year you finished
second behind Jeffrey's who took me out
of an entire field yeah so beat me in
that ten minute yeah I don't want to
start anything but let me start
something here
no but hopefully he is playing I don't
know either and then also that's roofing
Lee who I have most didn't even score
with so I guess you could consider that
kind of like a rivalry instead of a
one-sided you know right I think it's
funny that you mentioned roofing is well
because you and roofing and Jeffrey are
all in this tournament but in the three
separate fields yeah so you're not
meeting at all it's like we're really
holding until that junior close assuming
all of them play so you're 14 years old
yeah do you know if you are going to do
it in your heart you feel like someday
you're going to make it big as a pro
chess player or what are your
aspirations going forward people want to
know about the young guys to be honest
at this moment I don't really want to
think about so long term I just kind of
want to keep improving because there's
many parts of my game that I don't need
to improve in so for now just try and
work on those and see how far I can get
I guess I think that's a good philosophy
I wonder best of luck to you man and I
know sitting with six and a half out of
seven points
a pretty superb tournament so let's take
a look at the standings with just two
rounds left in his group if there's one
word to describe a wonder it's
definitely humble this kid has six and a
half out of seven what has been an
amazing tournament for him but like he
said he has not clinched it yet the game
of the day for Tuesday May 23 has to be
korilla versus fear the only other
competitors besides a wonder who can
still win group B after eight rounds I'm
here with another man from Group C and I
think we all know him pretty well
Grandmaster Alejandro Ramirez today had
black against alien is Nick and
Alejandro you come away with the victory
you know group C is we did talk about
this oddball group because there's only
six players as a double round-robin and
what kind of change in prep would go
into a double round-robin than the
single round-robin do you prepare more
for each players it's definitely got a
psychological difference that's converse
no single round-robin because while
you're facing the first the same person
twice and that means that the result of
the first game sometimes impacts a
little bit about how you feel going into
the second game I guess the same person
I haven't changed my prep too much based
on this but I have been a little bit
more worried about what people like to
do and how they've been playing in the
tournament so for example after five
rounds I was on minus three so I know a
lot of people were hungry to come and
beat me because well they had already
played me once and I had luck on my
games so they wanted to you know come
back and leave me again
so there's definitely that
uncomfortableness I guess of playing
somebody twice and having lost the first
game well today you had what I would
consider a pretty decent victory over it
niche Nick take us through the game and
show us the point yeah I'll go pretty
quickly Ilya it's a very quick player
and he decimated me on round one I mean
he should have been a draw in many forms
and I decided I'm going to keep pressing
keep pressing and at some point I was
just lost that was just really bad but
today she played some kind of odd beat
opening here with g3 and allowing this
ePHI very early on I played I think a
good move
DC 693 + f5 opening up the position on
the Kings side while his pieces are
passive from the Queen side I think is
very thematic already his position is
very unpleasant I mean I'm not sure I'm
winning but it's very unpleasant I'm got
into a little bit of time trouble here
actually mr. seasick surprised me but to
be fair I didn't know what else he was
going to do the point of this last
things that I played Bishop f6 is to
play Bishop g5 and this rook on c1
doesn't have a lot of squares on top of
that he really wants to play Queen d2 in
many variations because the Queen here
attacks h6 and there's tricks with
Knight takes a5 but here a Bishop f6
Bishop g5 just stops anything like that
so perhaps not really finding any moves
he decided to take on c6 but now his
flight scores are obviously very weak 9
takes c6 Bishop a3 at least he removes
the knight from before and I did I just
started playing kind of natural moves
rooty 6 to double up on the e-file 9g -
Bishop g5 just to not allow 9 F for Rafi
to root CA Queen f1 and here probably I
didn't play the best I mean I think
Queen d5 is probably just better but I
have a stable advantage and time was
kind of sticking so I decided to play
logical moves that didn't let him at
least break out of this position the
queen h7 makes sense just to the fact
the pawn on d3 rook goes to d1 and
Bishop d6 I think is probably the worst
move that I put in the game but I don't
know exactly what to do and it was a
comfortable enough move that it forced
him to do something and it was very
unclear what he's doing the bishop is
slightly better placed on g6 because
sometimes the rook on yet is defended
and this is kind of weird but here I
just didn't see anything immediate so I
decided to improve my position slightly
I'm sure the computer will hate this
move I haven't looked at it always so
yes but I would be very surprised if
like Bishop g6 and one of the many ideas
is that it allows me to play Queen f7
Queen f3 which I did in the game so he
plays rugby too just to defend the first
rank 91 and here again because time was
a little low as I said it we need to
trade Queens was the safest way because
after take stakes I have an obvious bind
King f1 and here I have a trick or I
mean I can trick myself if I take only
one take only one fish it takes d3 King
g1 I actually cannot take on b1 at the
end and win upon because my record is
hanging so that's why I play King a
seven because now the rooks defended
Ricky sign perhaps was a little clumsy
but it's probably fine rook e1 just
shows how pathetic rook the rooks are
really he's withdrawing from this idea
of route XE one which it takes and
winning a pawn but I mean Roque one is
such a Sabbath to play I play Bishop f5
mainly because when I play about five
remember I think I just like oh yeah and
there are some ideas with f4 that he had
and now I can always just take a nap
turning Bishop h3 just does a point also
the business is better placed on a5
now the rooks defended so I don't need
the bishop on g6 and the bishop can now
transfer to other diagonals you play bit
should be too I played h5 running maybe
to play h4 why not 9g to again time was
low so I decided to repeat moves he's
forced to go like this and I play night
before which is obviously obviously just
forces some stuff for example is equals
91
I was just depends on d3 probably the
easiest is to keep the bind as you can
see what actually only has one front
which is Bishop takes d4 and if I play
Bishop f6 kind of run side of moves it
doesn't really have anything to play
here cannot take 185 because this Bishop
on b2 is hanging it's just the side
positional around he's not exactly in
its exact but I really don't know what
its next move is meanwhile I'm going to
slowly improve my position play
something like b6
c5 even night c2 is going to be an idea
at some point he can clearly go roof c1
because I have 92 93 so it's just really
sad the bishop takes before I think just
loses because Bishop takes c3 and I saw
this before I play night before that
after King g1 Bishop C - I thought
rookie one was forced I don't see where
else is written go room takes is forced
because I don't have facial takes b3
because 95 check and then suddenly white
is winning well perhaps winning strong
word boy
the tables have turned rotate c1 check
this forced doesn't matter if he takes
with the rook of the night the trick is
the same night take c1 which it takes b3
and well if you move the knight
somewhere like e5 then after King e6
between the pair of bishops the extra
pawn and the weak King on g1 I mean it's
completely winning position he decided
to play Knight takes e5 which just makes
his makes him suffer less because after
Bishop d5 which is what I was planning
from the beginning the bishop is
completely dominating the night and
there's no way to prevent b6 for example
if he plays route b1 b6 anyway because
he cannot take them before because he
one hangs with me and that's actually no
way he can defend against b6 which is
actually lost
he played Bishop c3 and I have two ways
of winning at all 92 was winning that's
the bishop and I can play b6 next move
or what I did in the game which I
thought was also winning Bishop f6 and
here he resigned because while the only
move he has is Bishop takes and I take
I'm obviously turning b6 and after rook
b1 b6 and I'd be 3 which it takes b3 he
cannot take on BC again because Ricky
won
yes so this move the night away and now
there's this trick that the bit both
pieces around row attack but I have a
counter trick with rook e8 which
threatens route d1 check if takes from
d1 with some piece because of background
and if Knight e3 to defend against and
rupee 1 then room d3 defensive Bishop
and I'm off a piece that's not the only
way to win the piece but it's what I saw
is the easiest or the cleanest actually
you're not the easiest so I mean I'm
pretty happy with this game I overall I
think I was just better after I played
d4 and I don't think that I let go at
any point I don't think my opponent got
any counter chances so overall I'm
pretty happy with how this game went it
was a pretty ending it was a pretty
ending actually it's very unusual that
you actually get this motif to trap a
knight on the on the rim it happens once
in a while but obviously it's not very
common but it's nice that you know the
coordination of the pieces here is just
one temple
and after the night's fully tracked for
example if you had the night already on
g2 he can play something like 93 on it
and suddenly it's not so clear because
he has this tricks that we were talking
about with rugby one so yeah I mean I
thought it before I played night before
and it is a pretty finish I think it's a
nice finish yes well it's great to have
you in this particular tournament but
you're wearing a q-tip cats here and we
know that you're the recruiter and the
coach for Slough now that you've also
been doing some recruiting work for this
tournament that's not the players you
brought in here well I'm very happy with
the fact that I'm involved with the st.
Louis chess club and chess and st. Louis
in many different ways and this is
actually one of the projects I'm most
proud about the classic series one per
season it's an extremely important part
of American chess I think that a little
overlooked because obviously it's not as
flashy as the Sinquefield Cup or the US
Championship but they're the players
that are at this level the players are
playing the a B and C groups here neat
stepping stones to actually make it to
the elite and it's not easy to find
tournaments where all of your opponents
are rated you know 2500 plus or 2600
plus which are the cases for the BN egg
and a groups I pretty much try to
contact as many people as I can to find
a combination of interesting players and
players usually that are hungry because
if you can see the fighting spirit in
this event is really really high you see
victories with black and white
consistently you don't see a lot of
quick draws you see that there's a mix
of youth which is obviously part of the
reason we do this tournament is to train
the youth of America that's the reason
that reefing lee some Savion and
Jeffrey's younger playing we're also
training the slowest university team
members which are in Group B Jamil Jean
le mur Andy and in Group A Yaroslav
Jerry book and Dario spirit
and we bring together players that I
think are very interesting for example I
have a lot of Latin blood in this
tournament we have Alexander Sierra from
Brazil which I saw a player that is
extremely active I think he's one of the
most active players in the entire world
Sandro Medeco from Argentina that is
basically at his peak he just won the
zonal tournament and are in in South
America it's extremely strong and for
most of these players a lot of the times
you have to travel to Europe or to just
play a couple of times against 2600 so
part of the ideas that we bring those
players to them so that they have
consistently good practice consistently
good games and that they can improve
without having to leave us oil well and
I think it's really cool whenever I get
to talk to someone who say not only is
this my first time playing at the Chess
Club but this is my first time playing
in the US or even visiting the US so
that's really cool to have that
perspective too right it's not it's not
very good for us to like play the same
people all the time and it's something
that happens a lot in chess when you're
in one zone and just play against the
same players over and over again and
it's just not beneficial for your chest
because you get used to your style to
their styles and you're not actually
experiencing new things and well players
travel all over the world exactly to do
that to like not be playing against the
same people all the time and it's nice
that we can bring players from very far
away like Argentina like Brazil that
will show us new styles and they will
show us that you know how chess is
treated in their own places and for them
it's nice to come here is to do
something similar and to try to prove
their style here and say Louis and of
course the visit the club I mean South
America is really far from America I
mean the people kind of underestimate
the distance but it's good to have them
here for sure I couldn't have said it
there Alejandro is great talking to you
man
that's our pleasure yeah absolutely
let's take a look at the standings in
Group C after eight rounds there's only
two left
with a slightly different schedule Group
C has just ended round eight and Sam
Savion is in the lead and it is all in
his hands with a full point ahead of the
nearest competitor he is likely to win
on Tuesday Sam has the black pieces
against Alexander Shimano Shimano can
still technically win the field but it's
a long shot stay with us for the next
two days
Tuesday May 23rd round begins at 1:00
p.m. the penultimate showdown
and then the final day of play on
Wednesday May 24 begins a little bit
earlier at 11 a.m. Central just in case
we need to go to playoffs later in the
day see the move by move live as it
happens at just 24 calm and us chess
champs calm